[Music]
i don't know if you remember this one
it's called i want to hold your hand
remember
now the thing that intrigued me about
this is you said we as a band did not
want to come to america unless we had a
number one hit and here it is this beat
went to number one and you guys came to
america and the rest is history well
yeah you know with so many uh british
guys who just a little bit older than us
they'd all come over to america and you
think oh wow they're really gonna kill
over there and americans weren't that
interested and you work it out it's
because americans had elvis so a solo
singer wouldn't work so we
we kind of saw this happening
and i put two and two together and i
said to our manager that we can't go to
america until we've got a number one and
i said we just gotta wait we just gotta
wait just hold it
and then suddenly
this happens and
wow holding back and waiting was kind of
a brilliant strategy
you could have come and you could have
said hey maybe something will happen
maybe it won't but it was so smart
because when you stepped off the plane
everybody wanted to see and everybody
wanted to know you oh come on man
there's nothing they could say and that
was like that was the idea you know it
was like when we we get off the plane
this is the number one act arriving and
then we had a little uh press conference
with us all these hard-boiled new york
guys hey beatles hey bill what do you
know you know
i'm working on
well yes
we're number one in your country and we
did i remember we did a uh a photo
session in central park
and uh
they're all going hey
look it look at me look at me and then
we finished it it was all great and said
okay thanks you know and you go one more
one more for the west coast come on
beetle one more for the west coast
okay they were trying to show that new
york thing you know and we kind of liked
it
so yeah it was excising as you can
imagine when that song hit number one
you guys were in paris and you got a
telegram and the telegram said you guys
are number one in america was that the
moment where you felt like i could be a
real musician i can actually this can
actually be a living
yeah that was a that was a huge moment
to say is we talking you know we'd
waited
and here it was you know this telegram
capital um congratulations boys number
one in the us of a and it's like
well we just jumping around the room in
paris it was at the george sank hotel in
paris whoa that was a party